and welcome back to Long crime everybody
it is a mystery that has haunted the
music world for years who killed rapper
Tupac Shakur now Las Vegas Police
searched a home this week in Henderson
Nevada just outside of Las Vegas
allegedly tied to Tupac's murder I want
you to stick with me here because we're
going to tie all of this together so for
years it has been rumored that a man
named Orlando Anderson shot Tupac after
a fight inside the MGM Grand in 1996.
the home that the police searched
belongs to a woman named Paula Clemens
who's married to a man named Keith D
Keith D says he's Orlando Anderson's
uncle and that he was part of the fight
inside the casino that night in
September of 96. now Anderson denied
that he was the shooter and he was
actually killed in a separate shooting
just a couple of years later Tupac was
inside of a black BMW with record
producer Suge Knight driving police say
a white Cadillac with four men inside
pulled up right beside them at a red
light and started shooting Knight was
grazed by either a bull bullet fragment
fragment or shrapnel from the car but
Tupac was shot four times and he died
six days later at a hospital but Tupac's
Legacy has lived on Through The Years
albums released after his death were
number one on the charts and he was
inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame in 2017. in fact just last month he
got a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
so Brian for police to do this to swarm
the house it makes me feel like they
have something they're not revealing
everything but they might feel that
there's an arrest coming now yeah so a
search warrant needs two major things
especially for this conversation
probable cause that is an officer having
some amount of knowledge with some some
kind of trustworthy source to make them
believe that a crime in this case did
occur and they need to have
particularities what exactly are they
going to find in this home documents a
gun whatever may be so they know
something where they're just not
releasing all of it to us why right now
I mean because that's the question why
would somebody or why would they get it
now we talk about the same thing with
the Gilgo Beach serial killer like it
took so many years why now you think
either so someone said something that
hadn't been said in the past either
eliciting something or going down a
different Road I mean we've always heard
that Keith D has always proclaimed he
was inside the car and a major question
would be why not go after him so maybe
something changed but they believe it
you know how many rumors there are about
what happened to Tupac why they believe
this something maybe someone said
something or the idea is if you squeeze
someone hard enough someone will talk
because this is what 1996 when Tupac
died people have they're no longer in
the rap game they're no longer in the
crime game they're probably 50 and over
maybe they're tired of of living by
Street rules and now they're finally
saying something like a detective said
something the other day who had retired
from the case yeah do you think it also
has to do with the change in like
investigative teams we saw the same
thing again with Gilgo Beach there's a
whole lot of problems when this those
murders first happened now fast forward
they put a task force together and what
a few months later they started
collecting evidence on Rex heuermann is
that what you think you might have in
here yeah so Gilgo was a little unique
in the sense that and as you know we're
both New Yorkers the Suffolk County DA's
office has some people get cut and then
new people came in this maybe new
investigators who are not closely tied
to keeping their mouths shut maybe
they're willing to talk more I'm
fascinated by this I want to see where
it goes and I feel like it's you know
this is a development that we haven't
seen in years well coming up on Long
crime daily police say they have the
Gilgo Beach murder suspect in custody
and a former escort reveals a disturbing
conversation they shared plus another
possible serial killer now making
headlines on the west coast but first an
Alabama woman vanishes from the side of
a highway after reporting a Wandering
toddler to 9-1-1 two days later she
returns home and police are revealing
new details about the case it's next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody so we're bringing
you new updates right now in the Alabama
missing persons case involving Carly
Russell she called 9-1-1 from Ricardo
report a toddler on the side of a
highway and then disappeared for two
days before returning home on foot
police responded to Interstate 459 in
Hoover Alabama on Thursday finding
Russell's wig cell phone and purse near
her car but there was no sign of the
woman on the call or the stranded
toddler she reported Russell's
sister-in-law said that the 25 year old
called her that same night she overheard
Russell asking someone if they were okay
followed by Russell screaming on
Saturday night around 49 hours later
Russell was seen walking up a sidewalk
to her home authorities said Russell was
taken to a hospital for treatment and
evaluation and was later released in a
news conference on Wednesday Hoover
Police gave an update on what Russell
told them because there's been a lot of
speculation and attention on this case
they say that Russell left her place of
work with a bathrobe and toilet paper
that she had taken from the business and
stopped for snacks then she allegedly
encountered the toddler and when she
went to check on him she was reportedly
abducted but more information from
police may have led to even more
questions about Russell and her story
she started when she got out of her
vehicle to check on the child a man came
out of the trees and mumbled that he was
checking on the baby
she claimed that the man then picked her
up and she screamed she stated he then
made her go over France
she claims he then forced her into a car
and the next thing she remembers is
being in the trailer of an 18-wheeler
she claims she was then blindfolded but
was not tied up because the captain said
they did not want to leave Impressions
on her wrists
she said that they took her into a house
and made her get undressed she believes
they took pictures of her but she did
not remember them having any physical or
sexual contact at some point she was put
back in a vehicle she claims was able to
escape while it was in the west Hoover
area she told detective she ran through
lots of woods until she came out near
her residence detectives continue
analyzing data from Carly's cell phone
that was left behind at the scene on
July 11th at 7 30 a.m the term
do you have to pay for an amber alert
research on July 13th at 103 am the day
of her disappearance the term
how to take money from a register
without being caught was searched on
July 13th at 12 10 pm a search for the
movie Taken a film about a production
was conducted
there were two searches later to amber
alerts on a computer at Carter's places
of employment including one regarding
the maximum age of an amber alert we've
asked to interview Carly a second time
but have not been granted that request
what we can say is that we've been
unable to verify most of Carly's initial
statement made to investigators and we
have no reason to believe that there is
a threat to the public safety related
related to this particular case
it sure sounds like they don't believe
her do they it smells a little small
lettish to me yeah for some reason
Google searches aside and I don't know
why people keep going to Google for
these things
the inconsistencies that don't make
sense from things that we hear about all
the time someone abducted you but didn't
want to bind you because they were
worried about leaving marks that's not
something that people are typically
worried about but it does make sense if
you want to say there's no marks on me
whether they be sexual or physical just
so no one can really corroborate what
you're saying or go against it it's
really just your word against theirs by
the way this is illegal if she comes
forward and faked this whole thing what
could she be facing a misdemeanor in
Alabama it is false reporting now it
could be a felony if it involved like
a false bomb report or hazardous waste
but it's not that but I think it's less
about the jail time here more about when
on Amber Alert or a child goes missing
you want law enforcement to act without
any hesitation completely go in now it's
like the I guess the woman who cried
wolf well allegedly I mean there's still
unanswered questions about this we're
all trying to make sense of it could it
be I mean I'm trying to understand what
the motivation behind this could be is
it possible to mental health episode of
some kind so you're right it's still
Legend it could be that she's completely
telling the truth
um I would love to see what the
evaluation of her was after they found
her whether there be any physical abuse
that she maybe didn't know about and
maybe something to corroborate her story
to be a psychological evaluation I would
assume there would be as well not just
because you're seeing if the person was
lying but also the psychological
ramifications of being kidnapped in the
way that she describes and maybe it
matches up to what we've seen with other
people who are actually kidnapped or it
doesn't you know I don't know this is
this is weird I'm not gonna lie to you
this is a weird situation
situation all right when we come back a
former escort comes forward eight years
later after the arrest of the Gilgo
Beach murder suspect when she told
reporters about the chilling
conversation she had while on a date
with Rex heuerman
foreign
[Music]
new development in the Gilgo Beach
serial killer case out of New York a
former escort speaking publicly this
week about her date with suspect Rex
huberman eight years ago 34 year old
Nicole brass told the daily news that
she quote feared for her life after
having dinner with the suspected serial
killer in 2015. brass said that she
sought out wealthy men online in order
to fuel her drug addiction she connected
with fewer men through an escort website
and he suggested that they get a hotel
room but brass wasn't very comfortable
with that offer so instead they met for
dinner at the steam room Seaford seafood
restaurant in Port Jefferson brass
claims that huermann seemed totally
normal at the start until he asked her
if she was a true crime fan brass said
that they briefly talked about famous
serial killers until he eventually
brought up the Gilgo Beach murders she
had closely filed the case but claims
that heuermann described a victim that
she didn't know about in fact brass told
reporters that human quote seemed like
he was talking about it from experience
not a point of view she said that she
never went to police because there was
no concrete evidence to back up her gut
feelings at the time brass was also on
parole for a drug conviction human is
now in police custody on murder charges
connected to three different women as
investigators expand the search for
evidence in both Las Vegas and South
Carolina now the serial killer Saga
really doesn't end there because police
have just identified a person of
interest in the murders of Four Women in
the Portland Oregon area we're now
learning that the suspected serial
killer was actually granted in early
prison release 38-year-old Jessie Lee
Calhoun was locked up in 2019 on several
felony convictions including burglary
injuring a police officer and choking a
police K-9 Calhoun was released from
prison in 2021 a year earlier than
planned he was one of roughly a thousand
other inmates granted clemency by
Oregon's Governor all in an effort to
mitigate the spread of coven 19. after
conducting multiple witness interviews
this week police said that the they
consider Calhoun as a suspect in the
deaths of Four Women investigators say
the women that ages 22 to 24 were killed
in the Portland metro area within the
past couple of months authorities
believe that they have evidence against
Calhoun in the four cases but no charges
have been filed so far meantime Calhoun
was actually sent back to prison earlier
this month after Oregon's current
governor revoked his early release and
he'll remain Behind Bars until June of
2024. Brian let me focus on Rex ureman
for a second maybe just a creepy guy I
mean she didn't feel the need to go to
police it's the same time though like if
she said her felt her life was in danger
should she have spoken up then yeah I so
is that one little piece that you said
near the end where she said she didn't
sing anything because there was no
concrete evidence so my question would
be what's the concrete evidence now we
we don't know she knows he's the
potential killer that's not concrete
evidence in my mind I mean no just
actually I do mean disrespect to Men Who
purchase women for sex and favors you're
probably creepy and you probably have
poor social skills so if a sex worker
says that this guy was really creepy and
was talking about the guild murders I'd
be like well that's probably a lot of
your clientele like I don't know if
that's different than anyone else I
don't know but first of all way to judge
but second of all there's something
about it where she she claims this is
all about if this is true or not right
if she says she felt her life was in
danger and she had to leave and she
didn't feel comfortable going to a room
with him I mean a she should have just
reported that you know but again she did
have the past drug conviction but hey
you know shouldn't Chief just reported
that she felt her life was in danger he
might be a danger maybe she didn't know
he was the the Gilgo Beach serial killer
but they could have looked at him then
yeah I think this is an after the fact
thing of people seeing things it's the
same thing like you you you're the
witness you see something and then
someone gets arrested and you're like oh
when they ordered a coffee or when they
did this it was really suspect no you're
you're putting pieces together after the
fact in my mind especially the defense
attorney if you didn't see it then
you're are only trying to make it up now
or your brain is trying to make those
connections further so you don't think
that she's going to be like a witness or
something important in this kitten I
think the relevance of her testimony
would get knocked out as being more
impression it'll show them probative
because she couldn't formulate that idea
until additional facts got out of it if
this is true it kind of matches up with
what we're hearing that they're press
clippings and that he was researching
the Gilgo Beach Circle either he had a
fascination of this or he might have
been the one who did it Brian thank you
great discussions today thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America